the late President George Herbert Walker
Bush is back in his home state for one
last round of farewells before he's laid
to rest the presidential plane bringing
him from Washington to Houston yesterday
passed over his Presidential Library
where he will be buried today next to
his wife Barbara and their daughter
Robin mr. Bush lay in repose overnight
at his longtime church to give people in
Houston a chance to pay their respects a
few miles away mourners waited in a long
line to board buses to take them to view
the former president's casket bianna
golodryga is outside st. Martin's
Episcopal Church where his funeral will
be held in a few hours beyond a good
morning John good morning to you and
12,000 people thus far have come by to
pay their respects to the former
president here last night I spoke with
Reverend Russell Levinson who gave that
beautiful homily yesterday in Washington
and he said he was touched by the
outpouring that he's heard he's
expecting a full house here this morning
as well over a thousand people will be
attending this funeral we're told that
the public repose here at the st.
Martin's Episcopal Church has just
closed nearly 4,000 military and
civilian personnel from across all
branches of the US Armed Forces
including Reserve and National Guard
provided ceremonial support during the
president's state funeral President
George HW Bush returned home to Houston
Wednesday night
greeted by presidential anthem hail to
the chief at ellington Field earlier in
the day in the company of dozens of
family members the former president left
Washington for one final trip aboard the
airplane that usually serves as Air
Force one a fitting end to a majestic
morning
where mr. Bush was honored at the
Washington National Cathedral in
readings and the glory of the lord has
risen upon you and song
[Music]
and touching eulogies by longtime
friends like former Wyoming senator Alan
Simpson and he was a man of such great
humility those who travel the high road
of humility in Washington DC are not
bothered by heavy traffic representing
the family was former President George W
Bush who recounted his father's final
words I said dad I love you and you've
been a wonderful father and the last
words he would ever say on earth were I
love you too and choked up when it came
time to say goodbye the best father a
son or daughter could have and in her
grief but a smile knowing that dad is
hugging Robin and holding mom's hand
again former Canadian Prime Minister
Brian Mulroney formed a lasting bond
with mr. Bush when they served as
leaders of neighboring nations every
single head of government in the world
knew that they were dealing with the
gentleman a genuine leader
Mulrooney said that despite a strained
relationship it was important to his
friend that President Trump attend the
ceremony George Bush was the one who
insisted that Donald Trump be invited to
his funeral mr. Trump's presence
presented an awkward moment as he took a
seat in a row with all living US
presidents alongside her predecessor
whose legacy he's trying to dismantle
and a former rival he's threatened to
jail now may the god of peace but
Mulrooney said such moments present a
rare opportunity for national healing it
was great to see such a wonderful man
receive such a magnificent send-off
because in this case
it was richly deserved and as you can
hear and see behind me final
preparations are underway from the
Houston Police Department about 1200
mourners are expected to attend the
service here this morning former
Secretary of State and longtime friend
James Baker will deliver a eulogy so
will the president's grandson George P
Bush now afterward the casket carrying
the remains of mr. Bush will travel on a
train pulled by a special locomotive
number 41 41 from Houston to his
Presidential Library and College Station
that train made its debut in 2005 at the
presidential library where he actually
drove the train for a few miles and
incidentally over the past few years
she's become very interested in bringing
high-speed rail to the state and in fact
three years ago at the age of 91 he was
speaking with a woman who's overseeing
that project and said I want to be on
that inaugural train ride she said mr.
president
that won't be until 2023 and he said so
what's your point once again you see his
humor there alright bianna thank you and
CBS News will bring you a special report
this morning of President George HW
Bush's funeral in Texas you can watch it
right here on CBS yeah but I woke up
this morning thinking about that service
yesterday of course we were all sitting
there watching as many of the country
was yesterday the country said goodbye
today's the family the families goodbye
but I woke up thinking how touching and
how loving it was and I thought the
prime minister said it very best so
richly deserved for him yeah it was a
really moving tribute thought so too
[Music]